100 years ago today our 35th President
John Fitzgerald Kennedy was born in 1960
at age 43 he became the youngest man
ever elected President Kennedy's
inauguration address included a famous
line that still resonates today and so
my fellow Americans ask not what your
country can do for you
and what you can do for your country
but Kennedy was also the youngest
president to leave office he was shot to
death less than three years after that
speech CBS News contributor Bob
Schieffer covered the Kennedy
assassination he's in Washington with
the president's legacy and how he
mastered the megaphone of his age ah
good morning good morning Vlad you know
with the youth and the glamour and the
excitement that the Kennedys brought to
the White House they turned the
black-and-white movie of American
politics into blazing Technicolor and
then with his tragic death John Kennedy
became not just an icon but an almost
mythical figure to many the Kennedys
became America's royal family JFK had
some real accomplishments he created the
Peace Corps he committed America to go
to the moon and we did but most of all
he inspired young Americans to public
service the one thing that had the most
to do with shaping his presidency was
the thing that got him elected
television he was our first television
president the candidates need no
introduction the nation had never seen
the presidential debate until the
little-known senator from Massachusetts
faced Republican Vice President Richard
Nixon in 1960 historian Robert dalek
remembers Kennedy is cool and
presidential not so the Vice President
Nixon was sweating the makeup was
running down his face somebody else said
he looked as if they hadn't bombed them
before he had died and this gave Kennedy
a significant advantage those who heard
the debate on radio thought it a draw
some even thought Nixon won the
priceline has been held very well within
the United States
but those who watched on TV thought
Kennedy the clear winner in what would
be a very close election analysts said
the TV debate tipped the election to
Kennedy Kennedy became the first
president to allow live coverage of his
news conferences and he held on average
one every 16 days that meeting should be
probably prepared at a lower level and
then we could have he called it the six
o'clock comedy hour and the journalists
loved him because he was witty he was
charming engaging and handsome Kennedy
was briefly a newspaperman and his youth
he understood the power of the press and
understood how to put himself and his
family in the best light for a nation
that he is afraid to let its people
judge the truth and falsity in an open
market is a nation that is afraid of its
people through the new medium Americans
came to know Kennedy in a more personal
way than any of his predecessors which
made his tragic death that day in Dallas
all the more difficult to accept as a
nation we had never experienced anything
like from Dallas Texas the flash
apparently official President Kennedy
died at 1:00 p.m. Central Standard Time
for the first time an entire nation had
watched the horrendous scenes unfold in
real time and those who saw it would
never forget the fact that Kennedy was
assassinated has contributed to this
idea that he is a kind of immortal
figure he's frozen in our memories at
the age of 46 John Magaro enemy
JFK's presidency lasted just over a
thousand days even so Americans still
rate him among the top rank of modern
presidents he has a kind of charismatic
hold on the public's imagination and now
we live in a time when people are very
disillusioned with politics and with
presidential leadership and they look to
the Past it becomes a kind of life
Wayne Stephen Levenstein the author of a
forthcoming book about Kennedy sees a
parallel in his mastery of television
and president Trump's use of Twitter so
both of these men without maybe
realizing it entirely rode the new media
of their era into the White House I
think a living stone makes an
interesting point I have always felt
that the best politicians were the
masters of the dominant medium of their
time the founders were great writers
when most people got their news by the
written word Franklin Roosevelt was the
first to recognize the power of radio
Kennedy was the absolute best at
television and there's no question
President Trump used Twitter to great
effect in the campaign but here's the
difference I don't remember anyone
telling Kennedy you need to stop doing
so much television but everywhere I turn
and I hear Trump supporters saying if
only he would stop those tweets so so
Bob do you think he's become less
effective with Twitter now that he's in
the White House well he is going to have
to find something other than Twitter to
get this business about this
investigation into what's going on to
the Russians
resolved this thing is going to dog him
till the end of his days unless he
presents some evidence unless he
cooperates with a special counsel unless
he gets it all out there on the table
until he does that he can tweet til the
cows come home and it's not going to
make any difference
Bob Schieffer with perspective we always
appreciate Bob thank you thank you